A suit doesn't make a man.
It's what's inside the suit that counts.
It's resourcefulness...
and perhaps an open heart.
Well, what are you waiting for?
I haven't finished my drink.
This sacred institution
wields power beyond your imagination.
Winston, your brother
stole something from me.
What he took is very important
to a lot of very dangerous people.
Find him.
Because if you don't,
I'll bring the weight of this
whole institution down on you both.
Charon.
Show our guest the door.
You made a big mistake coming here.
You're my brother, Frankie.
We have to strike first.
And I need all the help
I can get.
How are we supposed to believe a guy
in an ascot can pull this off?
It's a cravat.
If we're gonna take on The Continental,
every freak in that hotel will be after us.
Well, that's lovely.
We need guns.
Lots of guns.
This is more than vengeance.
This is justice.
Can you dig it?
Shhh...
Let's take this house,
and everything that comes with it.
And away we go.